[Musique]
le monde des apparences
de ce monde des apparences
l'univers de l'entreprise n'en était là
pas exclu
et c'est salarié jeune moins jeune
diplômé non diplômé
de ce monde là
il n'en veulent plus
et je leur donne raison
alors bas les masques
si la grande démission
touche aujourd'hui de plein fouet
des entreprises de toute taille
de tout secteur d'activité
c'est entre autres
et probablement
avant tout
parce que bon nombre d'entre elles
consciemment ou non
son passé maître de la des apparences
qu'il s'agisse d'afficher des chars
aux promesses à l'échange
rarement tenue
des valeurs à la mode
rarement incarnée
ou encore ce que vous connaissez tous je
pense le fameux baby-foot qui trône à
l'entrée
j'ai vu aussi des murs végétaux pour
hors de l'eau des boissons bio qui
accompagnent la traditionnelle machine à
café
tous ces artifices
sont hélas souvent là
pour donner l'illusion
que l'entreprise
prête attention au bien-être au travail
de ces salariés
alors que trop souvent il n'en est rien
entre l'image attractive de la mare
qu'employeur
bâtit souvent un grand renfort de
marketing
et la réalité
vécu sur le terrain
par les salariés
l'écart peut-être de tel ampleur
qu'il va se traduire parfois jusqu'à ce
qu'on appelle communément aujourd'hui
la souffrance au travail
et un certain nombre de salariés y
compris des cadres dirigeants
mais préférons des missionner
mais ce rythme là
l'entreprise désertée
qu'à l'autre choix aura à terme
que de disparaître
faute de combattants
alors
ce qu'elle doit faire ces entreprises
qui sont touchées de plein fouet par ce
virus d'un démission est-ce qu'il existe
un vaccin
un antidote pour stopper cette
propagation
la bonne nouvelle la réponse est oui et
vous la connaissez
elle remonte à la nuit des temps
c'est tout simplement le pouvoir de
l'authentique
alors ce pouvoir moi je l'ai rencontré
très tôt et je m'en suis emparé très
vite
mais revenons à l'entreprise
pour passer de l'illusion à
l'authenticité
l'entreprise va devoir s'engager dans un
réel changement de sa culture
managériale
devenir une entreprise authentique
signifie
décider de ne plus jamais
considérer l'humain
comme une simple ressource
un simple contenu
et encore moins comme une option
et c'est au contraire
lui offrir avec authenticité et en toute
confiance
sa juste place
dans la co-construction du projet de
l'entreprise et ne pas oublier de lui en
être reconnaissant
alors me direz-vous
comment il faut faire c'est très simple
il faut permettre aux femmes et hommes
qui composent l'entreprise
d'exprimer leur unicité
on est tous unique
on exprimant cette unité à travers leur
talent
et pour ça il va falloir que
l'entreprise décide aussi de leur
octroyer le droit aux initiatives et qui
dit droit
à l'erreur
dans ces conditions là
ils auront plaisir à réaliser leur
mission
en toute authentification
alors vous allez me trouver très très
affirmative mais
qu'est-ce pourquoi vous êtes aussi
affirmatif sur ce pouvoir de
l'authenticité
est-ce que vous aimez les histoires
oui alors je vais vous en raconter une
était une fois
une jeune Touran
qui se destinait à l'enseignement de la
langue allemande
parfois la vie devinait la jeune tour en
gel c'est moi qui peut moins cher
je vais remonter elle est m'accompagner
on va remonter au siècle dernier en
septembre 1970 je débarque dans une
ville pas éloignée de Belfort
à Bâle
alors pourquoi balle parce que c'était
là que ce niché la bibliothèque qui
allait nourrir ma thèse de fin d'études
je n'imaginais pas
qu'en poussant la petite porte de
l'industrie
je passerai toute ma carrière je
n'imaginais pas que je ne donnerai
qu'une heure de cours d'allemand dans ma
vie
me le faire quand même
remontons maintenant rapidement le temps
en décembre 2019
l'heure de la retraite sonne
et là je referme cette grande porte de
l'industrie
je me dis
Nathan comment tu as fait
en tant que femme les gens exploit
de surcroît littéraire
pour intégrer
t'épanouir dans ce monde de l'industrie
très technique
et à dominance masculine
le tout sans connaître le moindre
plafond de verre
alors pour répondre à cette question qui
très sincèrement ne me servait plus à
grand-chose
j'ai décidé d'écrire mon premier ouvrage
pourquoi bien tout simplement à ce que
j'avais envie de partager ma découverte
avec ceux et celles
qui aspiraient à réaliser la carrière et
la vie qui allait ressembler
on me direz-vous de quelle découverte il
s'agit je vous ai dit je ne suis ni
ingénieur ni scientifique
on connaît tous je pense en tout cas
la découverte du Petit Prince à travers
le secret du renard
on ne voit bien
qu'avec le cœur l'essentiel est
invisible pour les yeux vous voyez vous
connaissez
écoutez je vais vous donner mon secret
à moi en toute simplicité mais sans
fausse modestie
c'est en osant être soi
en toute circonstance
avec authenticité et bienveillance
que l'on se donne toutes les chances de
réaliser la carrière et la vie qui nous
ressemble
ça n'écoute terme de ce parcours de près
d'un demi-siècle que je venais de faire
sur la planète industrie
que cette découverte
fut pour moi une évidence
j'ai réalisé en effet
que si comme l'a dit tout à l'heure
Christian j'avais pu me rendre ma toute
première entreprise
entrée comme secrétaire de direction
quitter comme directeur général
si j'habitais embauché par une filiale
du groupe Total
pour diriger deux de ses business
si j'avais été promu pour effectivement
prendre la direction des ressources
humaines de groupe 40 000 personnes
pas
ni mes diplômes
ni les compétences que j'avais acquises
durant les années
qui me l'avait permis même si ils
avaient quand même largement contribué
j'ai réalisé que c'était avant tout mon
authenticité c'est à dire d'avoir été
toujours moi-même et de l'être restée en
toute circonstance deux exemples pour
illustrer
nous sommes en 1980
je suis dans ma première entreprise
je suis depuis 6 ans
et je décide de vraiment provoquer un
entretien avec le PDG du groupe dans
relevé la filiale française au sein
duquel je travaillais
pour obtenir un entretien pour tenter
d'obtenir mon passage cadre
cette entretien va lui révéler la
négociatrice que j'étais et ce PDG
quelques temps plus tard menant à la
tête de la direction commerciale
et son fils quelques années plus tard à
la tête de la direction générale
un deuxième exemple
lors de mon entretien d'embauche pour le
poste direction du département
pneumatique 2 roues
au DG qui me posait la question si je
savais faire du vélo
je réponds avec humour
qu'il avait de la chance car je venais
d'enlever le stabilisateur
et bien
ma réponse a révélé ma personnalité
cet entretien a marqué le début de notre
collaboration
et ce DG qui passera plus tard PDG
maintenant bras à la direction des
ressources humaines du groupe
fil de ma carrière des exemples de ce
type illustre
mon authenticité mais cette authenticité
elle était encouragée par celle qui
était développée au sein des entreprises
que j'ai servi
alors
je le dis franchement haut et fort non
[Musique]
je n'aurais jamais pu rester
17 ans dans la première entreprise ma
première entreprise
22 ans dans la dernière
si pour y réussir
il m'avait fallu paraître
faire semblant
renier ma personnalité renier mes
valeurs
en choisissant délibérément des
entreprises humaines
qui cultivent l'authenticité
j'ai pu exprimer en unicité à travers
mes talents que j'ai mis au service de
leur projet mais également au service de
Maria
non je n'ai jamais voulu de ce monde des
apparences
les entreprises
qui
décident de cultiver l'authenticité
elle se dote d'un avantage concurrentiel
hors pair est-ce que vous devinez lequel
la différence
tout simplement pourquoi parce que
chacun des collaborateurs qui la
composent
quand il peut exprimer son unicité à
travers ses talents et bien par le fait
même il rend l'entreprise unique
et cette entreprise attire les meilleurs
talents qui veulent travailler en toute
authenticité
si tu m'as prises le petit renard au
Petit Prince
nous aurons besoin l'un de l'autre
tu seras pour moi unique au monde je
serai pour toi unique au monde
c'est le temps que tu as perdu pour ta
rose qui rend ta rose si important alors
pour moi
au manager c'est le temps qu'il
consacreront en toute sincérité en toute
authenticité alors collaborateur
qui invitera ce dernier a exprimer
pleinement leurs talent pour le plus
grand succès de l'entreprise et du leur
une entreprise
qui décide de cultiver l'authenticité
se dot
de l'antidote de la démission donc oui
l'antidote de la démission est grande
démission existent
[Applaudissements]